all right everybody I'm happy to say
welcome to our second big webinar this
is a 45 minute webinar where we're going
to talk about another key issue actually
a whole set of issues in Aristotle that
stem from types of friendship and
relationships I think some of you know
me already I'm the president of reason
IO I do a lot of work on Aristotle and I
use Aristotle quite a bit in my work
with individual clients and
organizations and then also an advocate
of virtue ethics so Aristotle is
somebody who's very close to my heart in
many ways here's what we're going to do
in the webinar itself we're going to
open with a few leading questions and
there's a lot of other questions we
could be asking as well and then we're
going to talk about four main topics one
is the nature of friendship in the full
sense Aristotle talks quite a bit about
this and then we're going to talk about
the main types of friendship that
Aristotle distinguishes which go beyond
just the three types of friendship but
but it also includes some other forms
and then we'll talk about a few of the
common problems and issues that arise
out of friendships that Aristotle
tackles and then we'll talk about some
issues and problems in contemporary
relationships that Aristotle of course
couldn't have talked about some saw you
know things like Facebook didn't exist
in his time and the workplace was quite
a bit different in ancient Greece but
we'll see whether Aristotle's theory
could help us make sense of those I'll
probably go on for about 25 minutes or
so maybe an amazing then we're going to
have about 20 minutes for Q&A and
discussion if you've got your mic open
could you mute your mics because I'll
just be presenting during this time and
we don't want to get a lot of background
noise right or feedback
um salt Aaron Aria if you think about
important to questions coming on Twitter
this may be related or not he died on me
or between the plate we can say it there
we go
if you think about some of the important
questions that tend to come up when
we're thinking about friendship in
general what makes people real friends
with with one another this is a question
that arises on playground when we're
children and may continue through the
rest of our life another important
question is should we be loyal to our
friends even if they do belong or bad
things this is just as puzzling to
ancient philosophers as it was in the
present when we see this coming up as a
theme in a lot of sitcoms and dramas and
other media productions and then what
should we do when friends or
relationships make conflicting demands
on us when we have more than one friend
and we're not quite sure how to
reconcile all of the all of the things
that that people are you know asking us
to do and then here's another question
that Aristotle himself doesn't consider
but I think does come up for for some of
us is it alright to spend time with
there be friendly with people who we
don't really like is there anything good
about being friendly not in the sense of
actually being friends with people but
which is behaving in a friendly manner
and if we look at these questions
there's certain implications that arise
out of this one of them is is that we're
not always clear about what friendship
whatever we understand friendship to be
is or involves or requires of us and of
other people another important thing
that comes out of this is that
friendship seems to have something like
a moral value
this is this is an aspect of
relationships and friendship that often
gets left out of other ethical
approaches besides virtue ethics there
is one other important family called the
ethics of care that's been talked about
recently that highlights that but you
know a lot of the modern virtue of
modern moral theories tend to see
friendship just in terms of other values
and we want to think about you know it
is friendship something that really has
to be central and in moral theory and
then if so what kind of demands does it
impose on us on should we you know
consider being a good friend duty or is
it something that we can do or not do
depending on how we feel about it is
something optional and another
implication that comes out of asking
these sorts of questions is that we
could use some guidance in determining
the nature and extent of friendship and
so if we ask ourselves where would we go
from that guidance there's a lot of
different sources you know there's
there's whole sections on self-help and
bookstores that we can go to and some of
them have to do with friendship there's
lots of blogs there's lots of great
podcasts but I think that we would
benefit by going back to classic
philosophical texts and Aristotle is one
of the great people to think about it
another thing too we want to begin from
where we actually are so thinking about
friendship in the present we use this
term friend to cover an awful lot of
ground and I think this is part of why
people sometimes get mixed up about the
nature of friendship and what friendship
would require so consider you know two
extremes one extreme is people we've
just met or inner only you know interact
with say on the boss or at the workplace
or maybe even only know through social
media we're going to talk about that
towards the end but you know it's one of
the interesting features at Facebook you
know makes us friends and then you can
have friends suggested to you or making
requests of you you don't even know they
just happen to know somebody else that
you know at another extreme we use
friend for these very very close intense
relationships and another question that
we want to think about is when we're
saying that some people are friends
what are we contrasting them with do we
contrast friends with say relatives when
we say you can pick your friends but you
can't pick your family or is it
strangers or our friends the opposite of
enemies can friends and lovers coincide
at all is that does that actually work
there's a whole literature and they
would say sort of songs and movies that
are important to exploring that that
common issue now when we turn to what
Aristotle has in mind his treatment of
friendship in greek philia extends to a
number of different relationships and he
focuses at the very beginning on what
the full meaning of friendship would be
as a paradigm for other friendships so
we can talk about friendship
almost with a capital F as the ideal
that were judging other friendships in
relationship and he also makes an
important distinction between different
types of relationships in terms of the
basis that they're founded on and that
they exist in terms of some of this is
probably a bit of review for some of you
who are tuning into the webinar let's
talk about the characteristics of
friendship and there's actually eight of
these if we look at Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics books eight through
nine and if we especially supplement it
with another book Isis which is called
you Demian ethics so one key thing is
friendship is inherently personal it has
to do with with the relationship between
people it's not about you know a
relationship to a bottle of beer or a
ton of salt or or even you know your
iPhone and we might get into questions
about well what about animals in our
pets our depends on whether we see them
as as persons there may be something
quasi friendship from Aristotle's
perspective about that but it really it
has to be between people
it also involves wishing good or wishing
well for the other wanting one or the
other person to have something good this
is integral to the affection that is
part of friendship so this is this is a
key idea the wishing good has to be
reciprocal and it has to be mutual or
you don't really have a friendship in
that case you have one person who wishes
the other person well but the other
person may not care about their the
person who's wishing them well at all we
wouldn't really call that a friendship
and Aristotle says that's not not a
friendship either another key issue and
this may almost go without saying is
that friends know they are friends why
does Aristotle bring this up well
because he talks about something that I
think we can probably relate to even
better in our own celebrity-obsessed
culture which is that if they the people
don't actually know each other and don't
know that they're in a relationship
they're not actually friends so for
example soccer would not would that P it
make friend relationship they would have
a high level of desire and they may
engage in a lot of you know sending
letters and you know presents or
something like that but the other person
is being stalked as bad friends with
that person you know perhaps that
they're a big enough celebrity they have
people who handle that for them so now
some other important characteristics
friendship is generally based on having
something in common with each other and
there could be a number of different
things in common and we'll talk about a
bit of that hopefully in the questions
but also in some of the content a little
bit later
another thing that Aristotle says but we
might find a bit challenging especially
in age of the Internet is that
friendship involves a shared life living
together and spending time together he's
got that famous saying that don't call
people friends unless they've eaten a
bucket of salt together meaning they've
shared enough meals that there's there's
you know
plenty of passage of time and meals are
particularly good if you think about
when you get together and eat with
somebody you talk with them you get to
know them there's there's a lot of
things that tend to come up that don't
happen necessarily in less unstructured
sharing right another thing that he says
is that friendship involves what he
calls deliberate choice and word for
this in Greek is prone a racist
it means the things that we commit
ourselves to the things that form our
character friendship in the full sense
involves who we are as people the last
thing that comes up and this this
doesn't happen in book 8 so I think a
lot of people miss this it comes up in
book nine of the nikah McKeon ethics is
that friends share joys and sorrows with
each other they in a way they support
each other through the sorrows but it's
also important to share in each other's
joys so these are all important elements
on friendship and there's a what we
might see as a paradox at first here
these features of friendship Aristotle
says are characteristic of friendship in
the fullest sense of the term the best
kind of friendship
now those kinds of friendships are rare
and sometimes a given person may not
have a friendship like that with anybody
they may not even know that that's a
possibility for themselves but it's
still a criterion so the question then
that we would have to ask is how do most
people know what these sorts of
friendship are like and use it as a
model we might think about the way that
culture works or you know stories that
are told or seeing other people who do
seem to enjoy that that sort of thing
perhaps we might think of it as
something that's built into human nature
our instinct for sociability when it's
most fully developed would involve
something along these lines so let's
move on to the second topic now we've
talked about this the fullest sense of
friendship
we can start distinguishing between
types of friendship and Aristotle begins
by talking about three kinds of good
that he generally will disentangle from
each other in his ethics and he says
friendships could be based on these
different kinds of good so we have at
the highest level virtue or the noble
good the in Greek you know took along we
have we have pleasure
you know the whole range of things that
make us feel good but not necessarily a
in the sense that doing good gives us
satisfaction but you know when you enjoy
your coffee
or you listen to some music that you you
like or you play on a sports team and
you know you whether you win or lose you
enjoy playing with those people then at
a lower level we have friendships on
what he calls utility or usefulness
to--some theorem in in greek and he does
consider those to be a sort of
friendship
whereas we might in our time say if
we're being very strict about it that
that's not really a friendship at all I
think that when we look at the range of
relationships that we have now we see
that we do have some of those then he
discusses what we call unequal
friendships and we'll talk about that a
little bit later and he also
distinguishes family relationships apart
from each other and hurt because family
relationships are to a large extent
unavoidable so that that's saying about
you can pick your friends you can't pick
your relatives Aristotle would be
entirely attuned to that so let's talk
about the three you know types that he
distinguished at the first light I
mentioned that there's three different
modalities or kinds of goods and bad
things that he distinguishes and so
these provide us with basis for the
relationships that we have with each
other
there is the Noble or the fine toque
alone and in Greek also could be
translated as the beautiful and the base
so when we're friends with somebody
because we really you know see something
good in them that would probably be this
the highest form
friendship and then there's the
pleasurable the opposite is a painful
you know some some people we are friends
with just because we enjoy their company
or we like doing things with them or
they give us something that makes us
feel good and then there's the useful
these are people who are not necessarily
pleasant and they're not particularly
good people but they're useful to us in
some way think about people who invite
you to a party or if we think about the
online environment they always seem to
know about what event is happening so
it's good to be in contact with them
right now these these three different
friendships provide us with bases there
are three different goods provide us
with different bases for friendships so
let's talk about the first one
friendships of the good or virtue
Arizona thinks this is pretty rare and
why is it rare well there's there's two
really good reasons one is that in order
to get to know a person you need time
and you have to spend time with them
that you're probably taking away from
other people so you can't get to know
hundreds of people intimately the way
that you do a really close friend I know
that there's that that you know saying
these days about something like 120 or
130 people or your tribe or stuff like
that but those aren't people that you
can all know with the same level of
intimacy so there's there's that aspect
of time and then of course there's the
requirement that if you want to enjoy
somebody else's company because they're
a genuinely good person they have to be
a genuinely good person they have to
develop what Aristotle would call some
measure of virtue virtue is a set of
habits that we have made part of fabric
of who we are the fabric of character to
use Nancy Sherman's really nice phrase
for that so this is not something that's
available for people who haven't had
some level of moral development
now these friends feel goodwill towards
each other
precisely because of who each other are
they're not friends with each other
based on what they're getting out of the
relationship they
big knives the goodness of the other
person that's what attracts them and
this kind of friendship is the most
durable over over time these people
really like each other for being good
people so you know they may have
occasional lapses but for the most part
they're going to approve of each other's
decisions commitments the changes that
they go through they will probably be
there for each other and these will
always or at least typically involve
some degree of usefulness and pleasure
as well you know if you're if you're a
good person you like being with other
good people good people are useful to
each other but it's not just based on
that usefulness or pleasure if it is
then we're talking about something like
this a friendship of pleasure and
Aristotle thinks that pleasure really is
a good here's where Aristotle would
differ from some other moral theorists
like you know the Stoics for example or
later on a manual cont
he thinks pleasure is a good it's not be
good but it's but it's a good and
there's you know if we think about it
what Aristotle says makes a lot of sense
there's two ways that we tend to get
pleasure out of relationships that are
based on pleasure we could be deriving
pleasure from each other if you think
about you know lovers who derive sexual
pleasure from from their relationship
and you know there should be a lot of
other things going on as well in the
relationship as so it's not just a
hookup but in that case there one person
is giving pleasure to another the other
Christians getting pleasure so that that
other person or it could be that they
it's not so much the other person they
find pleasant but they do something that
they both enjoy like in order to talk
about hanging out right hanging out
might be bicycling together it might be
having a meal together there's something
shared and there could be an aspect you
know that mixes both of them you know
you go to a restaurant you like the fact
that your friend can talk intelligently
about the the food that you're eating
you know or the drink that that you're
enjoying they are really there to enjoy
the food of the drink
um a few other things with friendships
with pleasure these friends are friends
with each other not for their own sakes
but for the sake of the pleasure they
enjoy so these these friendships are not
going to be as lasting as the friendship
in terms of virtue or the good because
when pleasures no longer experience then
the friendship will often breaks down
people say I'm not getting the same
thing out of it and it's you know
there's often times we have that it's
not you it's me
but the me is you're not giving people
but that watch right even here are
several things that younger people often
driven by their desires that they
haven't quite figured out how to manage
often fall under these sorts of
friendships friendships of pleasure and
there's nothing wrong with that
Aristotle things then we have
friendships of usefulness and usefulness
is also a modality of the good you know
it's goods that are instrumental for or
productive or sometimes preservative
although their goods um you know if you
think about the ultimate useful good
it's money you can use money to buy
things but you can't use it for much
else I mean you could of course decorate
thing goes with it or I suppose you know
as a napkin but but it's primarily
useful just for buying things and
friendships do form on the basis of the
friends having or providing some
usefulness for each other I use the
example of somebody who happens to throw
really good parties but you don't really
enjoy that person for his or her own
sake or you know find them particularly
pleasant but you do like going to the
parties there's a lot of friendships
like that these friendships are the
least durable and they often break off
of the usefulness ends there can be a
lot of disagreements about who's being
more useful for the other person and so
that that can be a problem as well and
then we have what we call unequal
friendships where there is some sort of
unbalance there some friendships involve
the friends getting something different
out of the relationship with each other
so I you know give you three examples of
the main possibilities here could be
that one one friend has virtue to offer
but the other friend isn't virtuous
but they can offer player to the the
other friend and a relationship can
exist on that basis likewise virtuous
people may have lots of friends who only
have usefulness to offer and that's okay
to some people it's a matter of pleasure
and usefulness when we see people
involved in romantic relationships where
one person it seems to be out of the
League of the other person and we say oh
I wonder what's going on there it may be
that sort of relationship we also have
family relationships and I'm not going
to talk much about that here I will talk
about that more in the longer seminars
but Aristotle distinguishes between the
relationship between spouse and spouse
child and parent sibling and sibling on
each of those and you know possibilities
for being certain kinds of friends with
each other when there's extended family
which could could be quite large in
ancient Greece and then we have
neighbors and fellow citizens and
residents so there's some sort of
relationship like friendship going on so
let's talk now about some of the
problems and issues that come up with
friendship and I'm going to jump right
into these rather than summarizing them
right here in order to stay on time so
one of the interesting questions that I
think still is asked about today
we usually frame it to opposites attract
right but the Greek sign is is
friendship based on similarities or
differences and ear cells as well it's
sometimes it's one sometimes friendships
of virtue and pleasure involve the
members being similar to each other they
offer something similar to each other
they recognize something similar in each
other friendships of usefulness tend to
be based on differences they provide
each other with what they need and what
they need is what they lack that's why
they're useful
unequal friendships of course also
involved difference as well so that's
that's another thing to keep in mind and
that leads it into the next question
well if things aren't exactly the same
how do we equalize them how do we
balance things out and so the question
that we're asking is what can people
provide each other to balance out the
difference in what they'll offer to each
other
Aristotle considers to possible goods
and and we might think of a lot of other
things as well so he says the friend who
is not offering as much can show greater
affection towards the other person and
that would be entirely appropriate in
Aristotle's view that's actually a way
to make up for the lack on the other
person's part another possibility
honor or respect shown towards the other
person then this might take a lot of
different forms but that's quite an
interesting idea another key issue when
should friendships be broken off this is
this is a classic problem that continues
on through the present if you read
advice columns you're going to see this
coming up forever in all sorts of
different modalities and permutations in
the case of virtue friendship based on
virtue if one partner clearly belongs
know becomes no longer good if they
change their character radically well
that that friendship can't last on that
basis it could fall down into a lower
level of course in the case of pleasure
Aristotle says when the relationship no
longer offers pleasure to the different
people it's perfectly fine to break it
off because that's what the relationship
is about in the case of usefulness when
the relationship is no longer
consistently useful it's not only common
but also in Aristotle's view acceptable
for that that type of friendship to be
broken off this is a really important
point to make because I think a lot of
times people remain in relationships
that they're not getting much out of out
of the sense of obligation or guilt if
we consider contemporary relationships
we might ask about
questions like these where it a romantic
relationships fit you know and what
about work colleagues so let's let's
explore those Aristotle does discuss
relationships between lovers and he also
does discuss relationships in marriage
between spouses he notes that
relationships between lovers are
primarily about pleasure or usefulness
and you know you could have a kid's very
awesome to find that one person is in it
to get pleasure the other person to get
to get something useful because they
don't find the other person at that
Pleasant and wormers will often end up
disputing what's going on in the
relationship each person thinks that
they're giving more and getting less
than they deserve
and so there's there's a lot of
interesting problems that arise another
question that we want to think about is
what do we expect a romantic
relationship to provide what what sort
of friendship isn't do we expect that
every of a romantic relationship be one
of a soulmate with somebody who is our
you know equal in virtue or do we you
know say this sometimes it's okay just
to have fun
worth colleagues is another interesting
thing to consider should we consider
people from work to be friends I'm going
to skip through this we can we can
certainly explore this in the QA which I
want to get to very quickly but we
should think about what kind of good we
provide them or what kind of good they
provide us online relationships huge
issue right I think about what we're
doing right now we are engaged in
something like a community of inquiry
through freeconferencecall.com what's
actually going on with that you know
Facebook is probably the most overt in
framing things in terms of friendship
many of whom may be with people we don't
actually know we can think about what
other kinds of relationships we have
online and and what sort of
relationships so we should have and what
would that require from us um and then
we we want to think about when we shift
from one kind of relationship to another
relationships are not always static you
know there's two extremes some people
think that all of your friendships
should be unconditional you know deep
your you're not getting anything out of
the other person and that
extreme that's that's almost
unrealizable another extreme would be
viewing all relationships in terms
merely out of you know usefulness what
can you get out of the other person we
should think about you know how do we
transition one kind of relationship to
another when the relationship goes
through changes or when the people
change and what do we do as people
demand that we do that what if we're
having a relationship of pleasure and we
like it the way it is and the other
person says I really want to know you
for the person you are and we need to
get much more intimate you know that's a
good question so I've gone a little bit
over but we've got plenty of time for
for Q&A we'll spend about 20 minutes
doing that there should be quite a few
questions I think in the chat all right
so Andy if you want to read them and
I'll answer each each question in turn
yeah it's a chat has been primarily
technical stuff mostly sound issues so I
think what we'll probably do is I know
that there was some background noise and
so we did actually try to mute everyone
rather effectively great if you could
since you're hosting if you could unmute
everyone and then we'll just let folks
ask questions audibly if anyone is in
listen-only mode or you're not in a
location where you can easily speak your
question feel free to post it to the
chat and I will happily be your voice to
realize that question to Greg in the
chat but let's start with them muting or
unmuting everyone and see how that works
for us for to start look I think if
you're not going to ask questions go
ahead and remove yourself once I unmute
you to it Martin you can certainly use
the chat if you like and perfectly happy
to do that all right so who's got a
question about friendship Aristotle
relationships are almost different sort
of like an advice column you know dear
Aristotle I've got a friend who's got
this problem that's right exactly
I have a question
okay hi dr. Silas my question is can can
you use Aristotle's concept of
friendship to put a build-up an idea on
our experience oh yeah so that's a
tricky one you're talking when you say
the public sphere we're talking about so
the political arena right how we exist
as fellow members of a political
community but we're also talking about
building like all civil society not at
not accountable Aristotle yet this whole
range of forums and institutions that
were part of that aren't part of the
state as such but we you know we do
public things within and I think social
media would fit into that as well
um can Aristotle's theory being extended
to day um yes and no like I said era
settled self made some attempts to try
to extend not the three types of
friendship that the notion French are
finished in the political sphere so
that's you know for example if we can
get citizens to exist in a friendly way
towards each other then we we don't have
to worry so much about walk warts and
justice we can get them to you know
treat each other well and to desire the
good for each other
and anything there's also an interesting
relationship between the political
sphere and the family for Aristotle you
suggested that family relationships
should be modeled on certain kind of
rule or regimes right so the
relationship between you know parents
and children should be a monarchy and
monarchy means where the ruler is ruling
for the good of all the people involved
not just dominating when through power
shouldn't be a tyranny right
they suggest that the relationship
between spouse and spouse should be an
aristocratic one where each does what is
best in their own sphere he's got some
pretty fixed notions about gender
relations when it comes a lot but I did
we could we could abandon that and say
something a bit more flexible now
another thing that the Greeks also
pointed out this goes back all the way
to Plato is that friendships within the
public sphere could be in some respects
destabilizing right because you think
about the the notion of giving
preference to those who you are
connected with in one way or another we
call that today nepotism or corruption
and in some cases it's really you know
it's bad for the society in some cases
it actually turns out to be quite good
because sometimes it means you know if
you've got really virtuous people or
help they're all putting each other into
into play but it can lead to a lot of
jealousy and and faction on friendship
is also something as Plato pointed out
or at least put in somebody else's mouth
since Plato never actually speaks for
himself that could lead to undoing
unjust regimes friends are willing to
brave dangers that other people might
not necessarily put up with Oh
so it's kind of long answer yeah we've
got several other questions that are
popping up in the chat so I'm just going
to start to go through those so I'm calm
okay so Duncan says sort of a two-part
here it says it makes me think of the
line in idiocracy when he says it's
really cool that you like money too
maybe we could hang out and then he goes
on to say what would Aristotle think of
relationships based on money and then
we've got about four other questions on
deck just so you know okay um well so
those are the relationships of
usefulness
you know when we're we're getting money
or or other you know you might say goods
that we can transport from place to
place from a person and we're not we're
not hanging out with the person just
because we actually like their company
or we admire them
um you know because of who they are then
it's a relationship of usefulness and
Aristotle thinks that that has its place
as a matter of fact we probably should
have quite a few useful friends and then
you know smaller circle of pleasant
friends in a very small circle of
friends in terms of virtue
so again somebody like that would be in
the outer circle I suppose Aristotle
thinks too that if you if you think that
money is the highest good you've got
priorities radically backwards because
money is only good for other things so I
said promptly and say that what's the
next okay so I think we'll go Kristopher
ever to the two-parter here so he says
first I like how moral development of
self and friendships of virtue are tied
together and then he goes on to say this
Aristotle say anything about loneliness
or combating loneliness your moral
development so yeah the first part you
know the really difficult transition is
you know what if your dacum
what you're not virtuous but you do
recognize the goodness of virtue right
how do you how do you trance trance mute
a friendship that at first might be
based on pleasure into a friendship
that's that's really about virtual
because it doesn't do you any good to
pretend that it's based on virtue if
you're not already you know virtuous and
from doing well this is what happens a
lot of romantic relationships to
anything so that's an interesting
question and issue that Aristotle
doesn't provide us with a lot of
guidance with but I think we could
unpack some of the things that he's
saying in terms of moral development now
the loneliness issue so Aristotle thinks
that the good life is not just a life of
possessing and acting in accordance of
virtue but it is one that involves
friendship that is shared so the
question that is what do you do if
you're doing that and nobody else seems
to care what if what if everyone else is
just motivated by money or ephemeral
pleasures or a celebrity culture you
know
it's very tough tenaris level doesn't
doesn't deny that I think nowadays we
have more resources than you know people
several generations ago did in that we
do have online community which is not
quite the same thing as being with
somebody you know being in the same
place and and interacting with them but
it really does fill in some of the gaps
doesn't it I mean think about again what
we're doing here this would be
impossible 20 years ago and now this is
something that we just do once a month
right and it's not sound really a big
deal and so I don't know that that goes
all the way to dealing with with sort of
being on your own in terms of virture
developing towards virtue but it
certainly it certainly fills in some of
the gaps so Martin has two questions
okay the first is how should the
relationship be between oneself and
one's superiors and the second question
is how could we adapt ourselves
friendship model to today's social
network worlds and we've got I think two
more questions on deck so we're call it
you answered either of those are both of
them however all right law is trying to
be try to be short with those so that's
the first one of the very interesting
one because a lot of you know last like
15 20 years a lot of companies have
gotten very savvy about trying to you
know use this this metaphor of we're all
you know friends together we're
basically equals I just happen to be
your boss you know and they did this
also as consumers right is when you
actually have a problem that you realize
that it's not like that at all
or you don't want to do what they want
to do and I think that it's important to
see those as relationships of merely
utility and perhaps not even friendships
at all perhaps you know a superior
subordinate relationship doesn't involve
friendship and shouldn't be understood
as involved
crunching well it could be different if
like you know your leader is actually
this virtuous person who you're working
with you look up to you know what's a
bit different those aren't that common
probably and so but then the second
question was about central social media
and networks can other things along
those lines
and one such thing Greg before you
answer that Mark Smith had a follow up
that we might just sort of combine into
that question and in his was saying do
you think that friendships that develop
online in anonymity such as in MMOs or
forum can develop into full virtuous
friendship his experience as such by
those involved or does the anonymity
serve as a barrier given that
participants are never quite honest so
we've got sort of a social network
relationship and then the you know kind
of cloak of anonymity that that provides
here so that is a really interesting
wrinkle added to it I was going to say
that I think that all three of the kinds
of friendships that Aristotle talks
about can develop in let's call it
mediated settings right where Aristotle
fixing you have to be in the same place
in the same time as the other person and
spend a good bit of duration with them
in that way and I think that a lot of
that can now be done through
intermediaries through online you know
through through talking on the phone
skyping you know writing things as
Facebook Twitter they don't lend
themselves quite so well to that but I
suppose you can read each other private
messages and and you also can at least
see some of the character of the person
and how they behave you can get to know
quite a bit through online sleuthing
about who a person is
now the anonymity thing that's a
interesting wrinkle
it's not necessarily that they're you
know they're totally inaccessible to you
if you don't know their name or if they
have a pseudonym or something like that
um
and you know I think that we have to
look at the friendship of virtue as kind
of approximate it rather than as a
finished state so perhaps at me it may
not be able to go quite as far in that
direction with anonymity in place but
you can you can still get to know a lot
about the person you know you don't know
what their name is but you know that
they went through this issue and
understand matters in this way and
respond to other issues in this way
great so I think I'll give everyone
who's chatting or thinking of a question
just another moment to answer but Greg
just before we went out of time would
you just give a very brief overview of
what anyone who is considering the
Saturday session might get yeah sure
actually let me jump in - there we go
the next bit of stuff so so we have
these two hour online seminars I don't
have a date on their coming up this
Saturday at 10:00 a.m. and 4:00 p.m. so
what we're going to do is we'll go over
some of the same material but we'll go
over it in quite a bit more depth and
we'll look a lot more at some of the
problems and solutions that Aristotle
brings up including some that we skipped
over like for example on should you
should you love yourself or is that
being selfish Aristotle's are really
interesting distinction between two
different kinds of self love and he says
that friendship for another person is in
some respects a Stahn loving yourself so
you know how does that work so we'll do
that and I'll provide some additional
resources we'll have that one will be
more structured so we'll have plenty of
time for going over material then
question and answer then going over some
more material than question answer I
also would like to mention that I have
some online courses developed on NIC and
Mackay and ethics books one through five
and six through ten we split it into two
different courses in part because
otherwise would just be a little bit
overwhelming because there's so much
care bill there and if you haven't
looked at the Aristotle playlist
sometimes
if you're wondering about some topic it
may already be discussed you know for 20
minutes in one of the videos on the main
YouTube channel so Brooklyn let's take a
little bit more time we can go over you
know a little bit of extra time I think
sometimes great when a little over time
well thank you thank you Greg and thank
you to everyone who's saying such nice
things in the chat window that's always
nice to see and we're glad that this has
value of Johanna has a question and it
says an issue that has arisen is not
knowing how deep were honest and online
persons might be comfortable with the
question might be ways to feel okay
about a friendship which turns out
perhaps not to be as virtuous as one had
initially thought yeah yeah that's
that's a great follow experience isn't
it you know we have that going on since
childhood all the way into adulthood and
and and it comes from a couple different
quarters sometimes it's that the other
person did willingly deceive us and
sometimes it's that we read the wrong
things in and they can have plausible
deniability it at least on their side
right this is because you know so this
really gets at something fundamental
Aristotle thinks and I think he's not
unique in this there's many other people
who think this that deep down inside we
all have a desire for the good and and
part of our good as human beings is to
have at least some relationships where
we have this sharing the deepest or
highest kind of friendship offers to us
and so that Prime's us to be able to
respond in that way and to develop
relationships like that but it can also
easily lead us astray and some people
exist out there just to you know exploit
that sort of thing um and I also
mentioned there's there's a certain
what's called them advertising
techniques or organizational behavior
techniques that also play off of that as
well so Aristotle would say I think
because he does talk about this to some
degree when something like that happens
we want to step back and say
all right where where did where did I
end up being mistaken was the other
person deceiving me that I did I allow
my desires to induce me to read too much
into things and we can there's not much
that we can do about it in the presence
other than perhaps recognizing if you
want to continue the relationship that
it's not a relationship of virtue but
really just a best a relationship of
pleasure or a relationship of usefulness
but we can think about you know for the
future how how would we how would we do
things differently what do we need to to
be attuned to and we might also reflect
on on you know our own moral condition
are we as far along the way to virtue as
we would like you know sometimes we
bring other people in again Aristotle
discusses but I think this would make
sense in terms of Aristotle's like
sometimes we bring other people into our
lives and become very closely attached
to them because they have qualities or
at least seem to have qualities that we
ourselves feel are lacking in ourselves
and so you know what that's probably not
the smartest thing to do on our part is
it so yeah any other questions yeah
there's nothing else in the chat right
now Greg so um all right well let me let
me then bring it to a close we already
talked about the other resources that we
have you can always email Andy for any
additional information about those
webinars or seminars and we will be
sending out to you a well be you know
taking a recording from this turning it
into YouTube video we'll send you the
link to that it will have the slides in
it and we can send you the handout that
that I placed in the additional
resources along with that that you might
find very useful so there we go
back up so some really excellent
questions some of those I will be
covering
in the online seminars you can also find
discussion of them in in quite a few of
the videos because I've gone through the
entire metric and ethics but these are
perennial topics Aristotle is not going
to go out of vogue on this matter
because the issues that he's grappling
with are are questions that were we're
always going to have to deal with in our
great great great great grandchildren
are going to be dealing with the same
problems perhaps in a very different you
know media environment but these aren't
going to go away so really great
questions I really enjoyed this and I
hope to see all of you in some of the
other webinars or in some of our other
online events yeah we'll see some of you
Saturday thank you so much and if
there's any questions like Greg said
just shoot me an email and I'll be sure
to get it to him so thanks Greg thanks
everyone have a great day